Mollie Kuramoto liable catalyzed make
sure that you try these supplements out
there very very good very healthy
natural and you can check the link in
the description box that is nature's
blend black seed oil and they have other
things as well oh yeah no editor boy boy
boy hope you enjoy the video so ok can
you come to me I cannot wait for my
breastfeeding you promise me everybody
is a witness okay indignity
it's mean you don't give me your boobs
okay you don't take off your panty and
you know what even if you are the only
women in the world I will not do breast
feeding for when you from us come back
you must have full of AIDS and now I
wanted to focus with me we arrived at
the motel
finally you will give me you will give
me your breast you like it or not your
promise what so now admit you save you
save you promised you promised if give
me Kathy you're saying this is about
muta you will do breast Julia for me
everybody heard you okay just tell me
that right now was gonna show this very
oh Jesus I don't know you are a [__]
like your prophet and this why you are
allowed yourself to bloom without all
this comeback like your prophet I can go
to the English we are trying to run away
from doing breast feeding for them you
will do it what is that man what this
guy's this guy's dirty this guy's a
pervert this guy goes you gonna do it
whether you like or no something like
that this is right this is sorry to say
he's finished after that man he's done
what he wants to come and speak to us
I've never seen anything I've never seen
anything like that and this is not a
representation of Christianity and this
is not a representation of the Christian
community
this guy believe me after just hearing
that now the Christian community are
gonna disown him I have four trusts I
have full trust because I've met members
of the Christian to me I don't know very
well they're gonna say this man does not
represent anything does not represent
the Christian teachings there's not
at Jesus do you think Jesus would speak
to a woman like that according to the
New Testament corpus according to the
scriptures according to their scriptures
do you think that Jesus will come and
talk to a woman and tell a take off your
panties I'm gonna breastfeed you and all
this kind of things no you cannot you
cannot you cannot justify this behavior
under any circumstances and you wanna
come on a platform with me and you wanna
come and speak to me and you want me to
lower myself and talk to you
you're a dirty brother you're a dirty
guy man you're a dirty individual you're
a sicko you're a sicko and that's why
you don't let it come and show your face
to someone like me
that's why you'd never come and stand
face to face with someone like me that's
why you're scared of the Muslim
community but not only that probably the
Christian community as well you're
coming out speaking to the Muslim women
are [__] prostitutes would you like
someone to say that to your mum to your
sister to your to your auntie you're
dirty you're dirty and I know you've got
sexual thoughts that are now permit you
crave and control your sexual desires or
you talk about is food and sex bro
you're out of control you're out of
control talking to a woman like that
you're dirty you're dirty you're dirty
you're finished you're finished well I
have finished talking about women work
like that coming to sex what the hell
you're a dirty man you're a dirty man
and you're meant to be some kind of
public figure for the Christian
community you're gonna have a following
with the Christian community you may not
have tens of thousands of people
following you how dare you Alec and yeah
appear to be honest when I saw when I
saw other clips I just thought that he
was someone who was low but when I saw
this clip this specific clip I was
against any Muslim debating him it's not
it's not it's not for me you know that's
for the Christian community I know for
my experience the vast majority of
Christians are not yeah are not anything
like that they would not endorse
anything we have to be fair there for me
debate in this guy what is wrong with
this is want me to come on his little
platform so they can mute me
yeah women being prostitutes what you
talk about my mom and my sister and my
and my daughters and all that you would
have kind of say that to me face-to-face
Europe you know what you are yeah you
had come to say that to me face to face
because you know what you are yeah you
would have come and say that's it
man to man face to face but behind the
little screen you're a keyboard warrior
you're nothing you're boy you're a boy
but you know what with I want to end
this discussion yeah with one of a
message of solidarity yeah and hope
because what I want to say is look we
might have a the Koran says like um do
you know comedy yeah you have your
religion and we have our religion like
you know if we don't agree on your
religion or creed it doesn't mean that
we can start abusing each other
it doesn't mean that now hate has to
fill the environment you have to that
you have to that you have to contribute
to a poisonous environment know if you
know if you really don't understand the
meaning of peace and solidarity look
somehow look at the Quranic discourse
well in I did AHA whom who then for
example or la caja whom gather whenever
allah subhanaw taala he says to a poem
to a group of people aha whom their
brother x right so obviously these
people weren't Muslim Muslim yeah they
no they were not Muslim yet however
allah subhanaw taala he said to this
group of people
aha room together yeah to this group of
people their brother was sent who is XY
z-- area so at the end of the day ah
whom we are brothers and sisters and
here for example in London in in in in
yeah we're not brothers a Dean and
sisters Dean no we're brothers in
humanik we're brothers in in tribe like
at the end of the day I was born here I
was born here you know in in London
we're Western Muslims at the end of the
day and we feel like we have solidarity
with the people in this country we feel
like we would protect a Muslim or
Christian or a Jew from physical and
verbal abuse we don't tolerate physical
and verbal abuse the like which we saw
in London London Bridget's act like that
we don't tolerate that you know and
that's the problem says ma he then Lamia
D there yeah tell Jenna whoever kills my
I had there was a noncombatant
non-believer couldn't ask a learning
this is an interpretation of it if
someone is not most Atman
as someone who is would you call he says
that includes a most Atman and am I had
an M and then me so every kind of
noncombatant non-believer we says
whoever tries to attack them and kill
them they will never smell the fragrance
of heaven therefore we say as muslims we
come together with the non-muslim
community jews and the christian and we
won also and condemned these individuals
a rogue black sheep trap individuals in
our community what we want is the
christian community to also do the same
for its community to flush out those
elements which are extreme frankly man
this guy is an extremist and i'm gonna
say that my understanding of the word
he's extremely yeah he's extremely
vulgar
he's extremely abusive he's using rape
jargon and he's justifying historical
genocides against not only muslims about
jews